congratulations thank you you're on the
list I'm so excited about this I am too
when you guys called and said that you
wanted me to be a part of it I was
really thrilled because that's a great
accomplishment for anybody over 50 years
old right I think so I think we've
discovered there are so many women in
their 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s having their
greatest impact in these years yeah it's
really impressive I just came from a
fashion show here in New York and I was
sitting with Martha Stewart and every
time I see her it's I'm inspired I'm
impressed I it gives me hope that you
know in a couple years when I'm her age
that I'm still going to be doing what
she's doing and she's sitting there at
this show multitasking we're talking
about Christmas trees and what she's
doing for the holidays and her business
and it just made me so happy happy and
it gives me you know another breath of
fresh air you know what I mean she's
always starting new businesses and
having new ideas and there's no stop to
it if I had known the reaction I was
going to get from my daughters I would
have begged for this interview a lot
earlier so they're very close here we
are here we are here we are girls I did
it
um thanks girls for the support
so seriously my platform know your value
um when we got together with Forbes to
create this list what we discovered is
it it's actually a wonderful message for
younger women
what's your advice to younger women who
feel so rushed like there's a clock
ticking on their lives or their career
right I think well you know from my
generation there was always a clock
ticking about having a baby getting
married starting a family and you were
sort of considered an an old maid if you
weren't married and pregnant by 30.
absolutely and that was really
interesting and just so crazy now when I
think back about that because you know I
have so many daughters and they're two
different Generations you know five
daughters a couple different generations
and everybody's doing everything a
decade later now in today's day and age
and even then some so I think that all
the boundaries that we feel like that
other people have set for us are
imaginary at this point and I think
people are finding their own power and
their own way of doing things and I
think that that in and of itself is very
powerful and you know what it gives a
lot of other people hope that there is
no rush I started doing my show
imagine when I was like 51 years old 52
years old by the time it got on the air
and it's been one of the most rewarding
chapters of my life this is my my you
know people often say well you know what
are you doing this for well guess what I
get to get up every single day and work
with my family and create something new
every time that we get together
and the you know the the creation of all
the the content like everybody calls it
now it's it's joyful at this point it's
a lot of work
and you have to know what you're doing
and eventually we figured it out but
it's been a great journey did you have
any idea that the show would be the
success it is today you know you always
hope that anything you're putting your
hard work and heart and soul into that
it's successful and I think that it was
always the hope that we would even get
picked up for season two
so when we were in the middle of filming
season one and we got the call from the
network that we had been picked up for
season two and we hadn't even finished
you know see and we and then got the
news that there would be no break we're
just going to keep filming we kind of
took a deep breath and went okay you
know this is what this is like because
it was foreign territory so you coined
the term momager okay and um you've said
that you're the family CEO right I am
okay
um and you're paid a 10 manager's fee on
the gross income from your family's
deals that's pretty good Chris well you
know when we started working together
there was no formal agreement per se and
we were trying to figure things out and
I Knew by talking to everybody in town
and I knew so many people and I have a
network of friends and family that are
in the business and most managers and
those type of people agents are getting
between 20 and 25 percent sometimes
Thirty of the gross and so I said to my
kids look I'm going to put my heart and
soul into this I'm going to work hard
and I'll take 10 because that'll make it
worth my wild I'm not going to charge
you the industry standard which I
thought was super fair and then I knew
that in order to get anything I knew how
hard I was going to have to work and
just wanted to make sure that I didn't
need to get a day job so you were like
kids I'm giving you a deal
I'm interested in knowing when you
realized you were the head
of a business Enterprise and not just a
family
the first time I really
started building an infrastructure you
know and got the right people in the
right positions and in-house counsel and
you know just all of the necessary folks
and team members to
make the machine you know work and it
you know whether or not you're there you
know making every single decision we
needed to First build the infrastructure
and make sure that we were doing all the
things that
um you know the girls wanted out of a
business and there's a lot of them and
then me and my son so there's seven of
us you know that we had to sort of
structure a business and you start
throwing spaghetti against the wall like
in the beginning we were like oh let's
try this or let's try that and you know
you finally figure out that really what
was working was the things that the
girls were most passionate about
and creating those kind of businesses
really you know was very successful for
us and really resonated in how much
joy and and fun you're getting out of it
too because it can't just be a grind
right constantly that's just not healthy
so much work
um and you guys have gotten to the point
where you have so much power and so much
influence
um and I think it's safe to say that
much of the American public and a lot of
uh women of all ages actually look at
your family as a model like what to wear
what kind of makeup to use how to use it
how to present yourselves and a lot of
that influence happens on social media
which is something that is really we've
all kind of evolved with it over the
past decade For Better or For Worse
and the data has shown now we're
learning that a lot of time on social
media for young girls has been linked to
depression body image issues self-esteem
issues how do you view the family
business
responsibility in this ecosystem as we
are learning so much
well so that's a a really uh a big
question I think that I'll start with
this I think that when we first started
our show
there was no Instagram there was no
Snapchat there was no Tick Tock there
was barely Twitter and
um Kim was really the first one who got
on Twitter and taught the rest of us how
to navigate the sis you know the
community and everything that was going
on and she was really the first one that
I knew about that learned how to
communicate with the followers and the
fans and the people that watch the show
and really use it as a tool like a
marketing tool but also to find out what
they were really interested in and so in
the early days she would go on and ask
I'm going to do this fragrance packaging
what color should I do and they would
you know give a lot of input and she
would actually follow their advice and
it became this really successful tool
for us and as Instagram evolved and as
it got more
um
you know the more Millions hundreds of
millions of followers you know you
started as a family we have over a
billion followers right now and with
that comes a lot of responsibility
because people do look up to the girls
and they really do follow their advice
whether it be fashion or you know
whatever else that we're doing and and
just the the creative aspect of what the
girls love to to put out there but we
feel very
um uh you know responsible but also pay
attention to what we're posting and when
we're posting it you know we've learned
a lot of lessons along the way yeah and
in real time in real time and we learned
don't post where you are but also you
know we have to we like to post really
aspirational things and and things that
make people feel good and things that
show people you know fun experiences
that we've had show people our respect
when something there's a world
Global event that happens like when the
queen has just passed away and we were
able to pay our respects to that and
able to celebrate holidays online and
and show happiness and some funny things
and you know I think it's a blend and
it's a mix and I think if you start to
get I know a lot of people you know the
the social media platforms have become
dangerous and for young people I have 12
grandchildren and I worry about that and
what I worry about is how negative and
dark and and nasty people can be and it
can really be very upsetting I can be on
social media and get 5 000 messages
about you know how fabulous somebody
might think you look or act or whatever
like positive messages about anything
and then one person says you know you're
awful or you know I won't you know
something
it's nasty and I grew up in a generation
where my grandmother always taught us
you know if you don't have anything nice
to say don't say anything at all that's
how I was raised so to have people that
you've never met you know that
they can just say whatever they want and
I think
I have we have really thick skin as a
family we're used to it and we can
handle it but there's a lot of people
out there
that are really affected by
nasty messages and it's very powerful in
the worst way and that's what I worry
about for my children my grandchildren
other people at the the world's children
because people do have
um there's been a history of you know
mental health problems and suicides and
you know just horrible things going on
for people that don't really
people don't realize how powerful their
words can be and they really have to
think before they post do you have um I
have a you know my know your value
platform teaches women to know their
value and communicate it effectively it
has a lot to do with negotiating any
Keys any tips that you have to
negotiating effectively like how do how
do you do it well if somebody says no
you're talking to the wrong person
that's always my motto but I think in a
negotiation a great negotiation is when
both sides win if you can give a little
and they can give a little and you can
come to terms you know it's interesting
you ask me this question because I had a
meeting this morning with somebody that
we were negotiating with
for one of my daughters about a year and
a half ago and it didn't go great
because both sides were unhappy and we
had a meeting this morning
and he looked at me and I looked at him
and we both just said that didn't go
well did it let's start over and we both
pressed reset and we pressed reset today
on something that was really special and
that meant a lot to one of my girls so I
that taught me a lesson like you know I
I wasn't willing to back down he wasn't
willing to back down but then we both
came to the table today and said you
know what I can live with that if you
can live with this and so when you you
know can do that with somebody I think
you really have to take a deep breath if
it gets heated and be rational and I
think that I have learned not to be so
impatient these days the older I get let
it play out a little bit yeah that that
song my granddaughter sings patience
patience I need something yeah
um you've been described uh as one of
the most powerful people in Hollywood do
you feel that you're at the peak of your
power
is there more to come
I hope so I never I never want to think
that you know
you've exercised everything that you
have I think that to to feel like
there's a lot more to come and there's
more chapters is very exciting for me
and it inspires me that's why I love
listening to other people's stories I
love to watch The Master Class series I
love to watch
documentaries I love to hear about
people's Journeys because I think that
we can as women can not only Empower
each other and Inspire each other but I
feel like I have a responsibility to
show my grandkids and my children what
getting older looks like you know in
some days I don't feel like showing
anybody what getting older looks like
because I'm tired or I'm you know it's a
Sunday and I want to do nothing so you
have to learn how to like give yourself
that gift of relaxing once in a while
but also I think that it rejuvenates me
like it gives me
a little bit more
energy to go out and try something new
and I love trying new things and
learning new stuff and my kids keep me
inspired and I think that the advice
that I would give to anybody over 50 is
to say if you don't have 300 kids like I
do and that you have to keep going is
like the friends that you make like look
around and look at who your circle is
and try to surround yourself with people
that you can learn from and you can you
know be a buddy with whatever it is
you know whatever that you you know
whatever it is that you love to do find
somebody else in your life make a new
friend find some new people around you
that like to do the same kind of thing
and it makes life more interesting and
more joyful more exciting and you can do
anything that you set your heart to you
just never give up so with everything
the products the new Ventures the shows
the lines for Kris Jenner what's it all
about what's it for what do you want
your legacy to be I think my legacy is
that at this age I was a great mom and I
I'm a good grandmother that's all that
really matters I mean let's face it it's
just Families First to us always and I
think that that will always be why we do
what we do my goal in life
when I had kids and they became
teenagers and young adults was that
every single one of them had something
that they found they were passionate
about that's great and that I could help
them achieve that as something that
could be their life and their their own
legacy and something that they could
make a living at so that they could be
on their own you know be sustain their
lifestyle whatever they wanted to do
whatever their dream was
and so one by one that's that's my
that's the dream for me thank you so
much oh my gosh it's my pleasure thank
you for having me